that's tough hockey okay let's see here
Chicago Blackhawks but he knows enough
cuz he played hockey Oh what you don't
know I played ice hockey we've never
talked about this other part can I tell
you something he is an amazing ice like
a figure skater we've never talked about
yes he is elegant when did you play
listen everyone listening to right now
okay papa right a slap King right he's a
king correct yeah Kings know things all
right and I have physical attributes
that people don't even [ __ ] know it
yes I'm shaped like a dumpling right yes
I'm round all right in fact right but
Papa can ice-skate
Papa can play tennis he can play
ping-pong and he also can play um he
could wrestle can I also tell you guys
something
please look in the closet he has his own
pair of skates yeah
I've up our hockey skates powers how'd
you do that for since I was five
whoa I play ice hockey I could skate
backwards I know how to play I know the
rules
um Adam Sandler's Christmas party at The
Pickwick about four years ago and Bobby
brought his own skates because he
thought that in his head that if he was
impressive on the ice but you just skate
at a party why all right number one okay
it's not as if I don't like if you asked
Adam Sandler who's Bobby Lee he wouldn't
know who I am
I've just had like limited discussions
with him and yes I thought that if I was
like jazzing it up on the ice right I
didn't realize the 10,000 people go to
his Christmas party oh it's not like
it's small no well they asked me they're
like you want to go to Adam sounds
awesome I go there's gonna be like 50
people there I want to make it [ __ ]
drive to like Thousand Oaks to get his
[ __ ] stage sharpen yeah
and he was the only guy who brought his
own escape yeah and I did backward
skating and we didn't run into him once
at the party no yeah he is band played
yeah so they were in this one place
where everyone was and then we were just
at the ice skating rink but it was still
a fun [ __ ] party it was how fun was
that so fun yeah there's like little
video games and little sections that you
go and um a lot of comics and it was fun
I can't wait to you through the Bobby
Lee party what the you know I used to
have a you know there used to be a
Spaghetti Factory
yeah I've talked about this before I
would love to do a gigantic tiger belly
birthday party this is prom babe we
decided on a personal I want I want to
go to a place and this is the real I
want maybe we'll try a book with a
pepper at the Universal CityWalk I've
done it there also for a birthday I will
do a birthday party where certain
members of Tiger belly fans can go like
the die-hard ones like it's is it like a
lottery it's not just a lottery maybe
people need to do like a an essay video
submission or a video submission or an
essay but we we do 15 people 20 people
and then we'll invite maybe a hundred
and fifty comics guests crazy celebrity
write and have a big rent out a big
section of Cupido Peppo you know I mean
you'll have to spend some of my money
but that's fine
I like festival festive things and I
think this September is the right time
to do it because Papa's honest Network
sitcom Papa um that show I think it's
gonna get picked up okay we also do a
prom then because I wouldn't prom or you
probably do this is I I need I need a
reason to get into a ball gown again to
do it on your own you can do it we're
gonna do progress you're gonna do what I
know lady think you're gonna be my date
it's gonna go [ __ ] they're broke
probably a prom king though look at Lee
she's demanding she cuz she's an actress
now
next week but she was actually a she was
actually really good in there I think
you okay okay
[Music]